a niche dingley rand they have another
round tomorrow they will
certainly bounce back and for wang hao
and yonda palms you're winning with
black pieces you couldn't have dreamed
of a better start thing is officially
resigned so
mvl with a huge result that is a big
confidence booster without a doubt
yeah certainly yeah maxine bashay lagrob
has gotten
a another win against jan napomnishi he
ties him
atop the leaderboard in the standings
and we have liftoff vichy we're going to
have drama in the back half of this
event
both of them are strong players i think
ian is much more unpredictable for
magnus
but the problem for jan is the tendency
to be very vulnerable at times and as
many of you may be finding out for the
very first time this morning
the 2020 feed a candidate's tournament
has officially been postponed due to
concerns of the covet 19
outbreak as to maybe other thoughts that
went into the
postponement of the event but ultimately
it seems that
something many people predicted has come
to light
welcome back i'm so pumped about this
round eight is underweight but let's
remind everybody real quick
of what the standings were coming in
here in this historic continuation
for the first time ever of an event that
was forced majority robert
with the deep preparation that these
guys have especially when you see
the best player in the world who's not
magnus carlson fabiano carwana
playing this fast robert i would be
shaking in my boots
does the comeback tour begin right there
for the american fabiano caruana
he defeats who was the co-leader in
maxine bashed the grab and is now only a
half a point behind
yonder pomnyashi in the standing and
look at nish
take on f7 with the knight and it's
rover and there's they resigned i called
it
and anish giri takes the victory a
huge one boy are we gonna have ourselves
a feed a candidate's tournament
and we had to catch those final moments
shocking
and um obviously incredible news if
you're rooting for yana pomniacci
versus magnus carlson in the world chess
championship because he just got a lot
closer to making that a reality
max team looks pretty devastated he came
in with the lead
he is now just out of contention and
it's been a struggle in the year 2021
he's had enough and that is the official
result
a win for a player from the host country
alexander grishook
unfortunately for fabian caruana he's
worked so hard
he has been impressive he played well in
vikings a
and here we see the score sheets are
signed
that's a victory for anish giri he now
actually
leap frogs for the moment yonda pomashi
in the standings
black has to distract himself to attack
wow he resigns and wang hao shakes his
head
in disbelief and yon napomnishi with a
huge
victory with the black pieces i just
don't think that i can continue this
profession what to say that it's like
you are retiring from chess
yes exactly we have an official result
between yonder pontiac and maxime vasya
the grav as soon as
maxine played bishop d7 here we were
likely about to see a repeating of moves
and
with that draw we are moments away
from declaring the candidates won by the
russian number one
depending on what happens in this game
between alexander grisha
and anish geary grishik is in no rush
here
oh there's a resignation did he resign
and he does
and we have an answer robert who will
play magnus carlsen
in november in dubai yonder parmiasi
all of his lifelong hard work paying off
so he can face magnus carlsen
when the moment is brightest when the
stage is the biggest it does
seem like jan napoli steps up and he can
handle the task